Donald Trump has a real problem with
black people even though he recently
said he would win the black vote he's
actually polling somewhere between one
and two percent statistically zero in
some individual states a recent poll in
Ohio had Trump polling zero now Louis
that doesn't mean no black people are
voting for Trump in Ohio what it means
is statistically it didn't even make it
to one percent in the poll and that's
bad enough yeah uh I'm not sure how
it'll happen but I'm hoping at some
point he'll reach negative one or two
presented with the black vote so Trump
decides to go after the black vote is
going to court the black vote and like
most things in the Donald Trump campaign
he seems to end up doing the opposite of
what's logical he decided to go make an
appeal to the black vote in front of yet
another mostly white crowd and just said
untruth after untruth about black people
I don't know that Trump said anything
accurate about black people in this
speech other than the fact that he seem
to acknowledge them as black people
right he seems to be talking about them
as if they are part of Homo sapiens
that's the only relatively accurate
thing in the entire discussion here I
will play the clip for you this is Trump
speaking in dimondale Michigan which is
ninety six point four percent white and
he made a horribly misinformed appeal to
black people take a look what do you
have to lose by trying something new
like Trump what do you have to lose
right
good luck with it I say it again what do
you have to lose look what do you have
to lose you're living in poverty your
schools are no good you have no jobs
fifty-eight percent of your youth is
unemployed right what the hell do you
have to lose he then double down on the
insane going on the Jeanine Pirro show
on Fox News which we could do a couple
hours on that show alone I mean that
that show is insane uh so he goes on one
of the most heinous and depraved shows
on one of the most heinous in the brave
networks and it's totally Looney Tunes
he said black people have no education
either take a listen gentlemen you know
is in my speech and I really thought of
just was reading the statistics where
you have forty percent of living in
poverty fifty-eight percent of the of
the students I mean the young people
they can't get jobs and you know just
like a total catastrophe the
unemployment rates everything is bad no
health care no education no anything
know anything that poverty is
unbelievable and then i said hey wait a
minute vote for me what do you have to
lose i can't do worse you can't do any
worse than what these people have been
doing and i will do better and actually
said that if you vote for me the next
time in four years i'll get 95% you vote
to give assistant to bigger brother when
you say you're living in poverty you're
clearly implying are saying that poverty
is something that afflicts most or a
majority of the group in this particular
case black Americans otherwise why would
you say it that way yes black americans
have a higher than average poverty rate
around a quarter compared to a ten
percent overall but he's saying that uh
yeah basically poverty is just it's a
but most black people are poor so why
not vote for me he said black people are
sending kids to failing schools as if
that's the fault of black people that
schools in disproportionately black
areas I have problems it in fact Trump
part of his platform is to take away
federal funding from education which
would only make those so-called black
schools be even worse off yeah well it's
part of the whole Donald Trump thing
that I can improve everything yeah
everything will be better under me and
they're just telling people that they're
completely destitute
and have absolutely nothing to lose
doesn't seem like the best strategy when
you say you have no jobs you're clearly
implying or saying that unemployment is
something that afflicts most or a
majority of black Americans otherwise
again why would you say it and yes
unemployment is higher among black
Americans as it is among Hispanic
Americans uh in terms of black Americans
it's roughly double the national
unemployment rate but it seems Jason
like Donald Trump doesn't know that most
black people are not poor and most black
people have jobs and it's like a
caricature of the population that he
that he seems to be focusing on here
well I guess when you say your message
is well I just kick any worse try me I
mean that the pre much does it all to me
right there you have to sort of outline
a caricature of how things are if your
message is I can't possibly be worse
than where things are right now because
that's your you're depending on things
being a disaster in order for that to
appeal to anybody yeah um it's uh and
certainly this is disastrous a place
where in right now but uh who really
thinks the Donald Trump is going to turn
things around for black people as he
says if you believe Trump statistics the
next question becomes how will Trump's
policies on for example health care or
funding for education or his view on
voting rights none of those positions
will at all help the black American
community Trump says well we need to
create job opportunities I agree with
that the problem is his policies won't
actually do that I have amazing video of
new republican uh buh buh strategist the
new campaign manager one of the new
campaign managers for Donald Trump
Kellyanne Conway before she was working
for Trump she demanded that we see
Donald Trump's tax returns so she goes
on TV and she is asked hey you called
for the release of Donald Trump's tax
returns when you weren't running his
campaign certainly you're standing by
that right Kellyanne Conway no she's not
take a look at the video let's talk
about Donald Trump's tax returns back in
April you said on CNN that you want
Trump to be transparent
right listen ask you about this alliance
between you first Kellyanne between John
Kasich and Ted Cruz this alliance shall
we say that Donald Trump is calling
collusion is this fair game are they
playing by the rules here oh absolutely
it's completely transparent Donald
Trump's tax returns aren't I'd like to
see those be transparent oh okay now
you're in charge of Donald Trump's
campaign I've given that and given how
you feel or we gonna see Donald Trump's
tax return soon so now that I'm on the
inside I know something I didn't know
them which is he's under audit and with
him mm-hmm and he has said very clearly
and I back him up completely yeah that
when the audit is completed he will
release the tax returns and let me just
say something about transparency it
comes in many different forms down as
does accountability yeah back as
truthfulness and we can't imagine going
up against a less transparent less
accountable more sort of rigged and
corrupt individual as our political
opponents in Hillary Clinton she had a
terrible week when it comes to being
transparent and accountable whether it's
the revelations of the pay for play at
the in the State Department they I know
that you seeing that is very much on top
of and your reporting is data as well as
as well as the what happened at the
Clinton Foundation and we are and we are
talking about that for sure but in this
particular interview and these questions
are about Donald Trump and and you
mentioned the audit according to his
lawyers the years two thousand two two
two thousand eight are no longer under
audit so would you release those tax
returns no no I would not this entire
tax return debate is somewhat
confounding to me in the following sense
yeah she just doesn't get why people
want this well the reason people want
the tax returns is the same reason you
wanted them a couple months ago right I
mean we did there there could be so much
in there being under audit doesn't
prevent you from releasing your tax
returns but more importantly everybody
knew Trump was saying he was under audit
and that's why he wasn't releasing them
how did it take her becoming part of his
campaign to learn that he's been saying
that for years and let me also add it
usually takes a little while for the IRS
to audit you the odds that trumps 2015
tax returns are under audit are almost
implement almost
and probability I almost feel bad for
her right she was caught earlier saying
that on video yeah uh and someone like
her doing so many appearances it's hard
to keep track of what you say sure I get
it uh and it's it's hilarious basically
what Kellyanne is saying is I'm on
Trump's payroll now you don't want me
getting fired are you or maybe what she
means is and this is I think actually
even more likely now that I'm on the
inside and I've talked to people on the
campaign I know why Trump absolutely
cannot release those tax returns because
they would be so devastating compared to
just continuing to not release them and
that's really what I think is going on
here send me your thoughts on this we
will take a break and be back with more
right after this at least a few victims
of the Louisiana flooding seemed
thrilled to see Donald Trump show up
there with Mike Pence in Louisiana they
acted like Trump was actually doing
something to make a difference and
here's people saying we knew you'd be
here Donald take a look well yeah he's
not gonna miss an opportunity for just a
blatant pandering photo op anybody could
have predicted trumpet is gonna show up
there yeah and uh server mission
accomplished it worked so then Trump uh
well before I get to the video of Trump
quote helping I'll show you this is a
guy who teared up at Trump showing up in
his private plane with a make America
great again huh give me a min 45 hours
but he didn't give him any yet but
hopefully one day he will if he sees
this go are you happy that he came here
oh yes sir most blessed with ya down
no Donald Trump all the way hey
everybody wait why did you lose and what
does it mean to have the whole trunk
here um let's see
I didn't lose anything up here
to what a lot of people lost I'm okay
it's materialistic things they can be
replaced having from here that mentality
oh yes yes the goal l America gotta wake
up right so here is the big photo op op
Trump spending basically 45 seconds
handing out items uh just helping to
move items off of the back of a truck
and into someone else's hands and uh
this this is the entire thing this is
Trump helping take a look lot of work
Trump is doing there huh he is
absolutely moving boxes applies be
starting to break a sweat yeah very
somber and serious Donald Trump showing
up here uh yeah so anyway I don't know I
mean is this is that helping I've seen
so many people posting about how Trump
is helping the guys in a suit wearing a
make America great again had how much
help do you really think he's doing in
flood recovery what about writing a
check Donald but that's really been the
problem for Trump right he talks a lot
about the charity contributions he makes
Washington Post investigation turned out
uh turned up that he actually maybe at
most a donated $10,000 a tiny tiny
seedling of a fraction of what he
claimed to have donated that's really
what he could have done written a check
do you think with all the money he saved
by not paying people who worked for him
even more generous with charity uh well
he is helping in the ended by definition
literal sense yeah I guess he did help
for a few minutes there right wingers
Jason are furious because all bomb is on
vacation during this time he's not doing
anything first of all uh presidents can
work from anywhere Bush was on vacation
during any number of train wrecks and
disasters that took place and you didn't
hear the
publicans criticizing him for that but
President Obama did actually declare a
disaster he issued a disaster
declaration which allows Louisiana and
people in Louisiana to apply for federal
aid isn't that such a flaccid criticism
will wear it where is Obama he's
vacationing Trump is here with a suit
passing around so well I'm sure Obama's
actually doing more by not being in
there and actually like communicate with
people and setting up organizations get
things done and don't rumpa shows up and
move the box from side to side write a
check Donald that's not that's not a
photo op for Obama yeah that's exactly
right President Obama is not taking this
as an opportunity to be photographed
holding but soap boxes Donald Trump's
campaign basically stands for almost
nothing in terms of policy and one of
the few elements of his campaign that we
could even remotely call a campaign
proposal is his completely asinine and
half-baked immigration plan and all of
these terms like proposal and policy and
plan I'm using these in the loosest
sense of the dictionary definitions of
the words he has this idea of rounding
up 11 million undocumented immigrants
paying for what it'll cost to round them
up paying to deport them all building a
wall with Mexico that he says Mexico
will pay for Mexico will not pay for the
wall we would have to pay for the wall
that were to happen and then letting
people back in if they meet certain
requirements of course other than the
rapists and criminals which from Trump's
hyperbole on this seems to be most of
the people that are trying to come in
from Mexico and points south it seems
that Donald Trump is now even
flip-flopping on that issue which is
insane to me because when you go to
trump rallies and you ask people what
policy of trumps do you like most people
have no answer at all the few people
that do say well I like that he's gonna
get the illegals out and he's gonna
build a wall and even on that issue
Trump seems to now be softening and
saying possibly possibly he won't even
be doing the deportations let's start
first with a clip from CNN on Sunday
when one of his new there's been a row
of revolving door of campaign managers
his new campaign co-manager Kellyanne
Conway was asked he's still deporting
people right and she said
is now undecided take a listen let me
play something from what mr. Trump has
said previously listen to what he said
back in November going to have a
deportation force and you're going to do
it you mainly light expenses out of
their homes in a chow they're going back
where they came if they came from a
certain country they're gonna be brought
back to that country as to its supposed
to be so does Donald Trump still support
that a deportation force removing the 11
million or so undocumented immigrants
what he supports and if you go back his
convention speech him a month ago Dano
down and what he supports is to make
sure that we enforce the law that we are
respectful of those Americans who are
looking for well-paying jobs and that we
are fair and humane for those who live
among us in this country and as the
week's unfold as the week's unfold he
will lay out the specifics of that plan
that he would implement as president of
the United States will that plan include
a deportation force the kind that he
just you just heard in that sound bite
and that he talked about during the
Republican primaries to be determined
wait wait wait wait wait everything now
is negotiable it's to be determined the
guy who says that they're all getting
kicked out by force is suddenly
potentially changing that plan because
by the way most people realize that the
plan is completely impossible and
unaffordable so then of course after
Kellyanne Conway opens the door to this
the questions go to Donald Trump are you
flip flopping on one of what I guess is
the three major campaign ideas ban
Muslims which is already completely
changed his position on uh deport
immigrants and build a wall Trump
himself insisted yesterday I'm not
flip-flopping he went on fox news last
night he said the first thing we're
going to do if and when I win is we're
going to get rid of all the bad ones
then adding that everybody else will go
through the existing process we have
which the Obama administration is using
and saying that that's what we're going
to do we're just going to enforce that
with a lot more energy does anybody
realize that of the few things the Trump
campaign stood for at some point this
was one of the major ones and II
in on this Louis Trump is saying
actually we may just do what Obama's
already been doing just with higher
levels of energy what does this guy
actually stand for that would be
different uh Trump knows he can say
whatever he wants but he knows and his
is his staffers managers know that he
can't do whatever he wants ah uh but
still uh apart from this is it's still
shocking to me that a year ago maybe
even more he was saying well I'm going
to outline my plan soon right and he's
still saying that now he's the nominee
and he's still saying well at some point
in the not too distant future I'm
actually gonna give you details about my
plans oh sure it's coming up anytime as
soon as he figures out uh uh uh who the
the the best way to couch it to not lose
the nativist xenophobic vote that he is
coalesced and catalyzed another example
of this Jason is last week or the week
before Oh Trump came up with the
brilliant idea of coordinating attacks
with Russia and other countries against
Isis which happens to be exactly what
President Obama has been doing on so
many issues he bashes Trump any better
I'm sorry Trump bashes Obama and he
bashes Hillary and then basically goes
back to I'll probably do what they're
doing just better and with more energy
so the next flip-flop the major
flip-flop he's gonna know it if he gets
elected which is gonna happen he's
actually change the Democratic Party
that's next law yet he's gonna change
the Democratic Party from the inside as
a Republican you're convinced he won't
win I mean you're saying it much more
I'm saying 22 of 23 recent polls say
he's losing but you're actually saying
he's not going to be President and
what's one poll Fox News ah yes it was
like LA Times USC or something like that
that's the one poll right now that says
Trump is ahead by one which really isn't
being ahead I mean it's the margin of
error uh yeah so anyway yet another one
of the mainstays of trumps supposed
campaign platform which by the way is a
joke uh falls apart interesting we'll
see how the nativist xenophobes react to
that hey uh Donald Trump is now going
hard against the host of MSNBC's Morning
Show once again accusing the co-host
Mika Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough of
being quote neurotic and a mess saying
both of them are total clowns
he's now threatening to tell the quote
real story about them here's a couple of
tweets that Trump sent out yesterday the
first one is tried watching low-rated
Morning Joe this morning unwatchable
morning Mika meaning mika brzezinski is
off the wall a neurotic and not very
bright mess he then followed up that
tweet with another one with a threat
someday when things calm down I'll tell
the real story of Joe Scarborough and
his very insecure longtime girlfriend
mika brzezinski two clowns why all of a
sudden did Donald Trump start tweeting
threats about media host which by the
way should uniquely disqualify anyone
temperamental II from being president of
the United States apparently he didn't
like this take a look had a great week I
think he's been on message he's shown
maturity as a candidate I think that
he's getting into a groove I think he
likes the new style that he's been out
on the campaign trail producing and and
then and and and speaking of so I think
he's done a great
everything's awesome everything so this
is the part I don't understand because I
think this is it I mean you just have to
look at this as an opportunity Micah's
completely right sarcastically saying oh
sure rinse everything is just great with
the campaign obviously the campaign is
not doing great they're losing 22 of the
last 23 recent polls and if that think
Louis what it says about a presidential
candidate if a host merely saying yeah
you know things are really that great
right if that makes it so you take time
from campaigning to tweet threats to
media people you are uniquely
unqualified to be President of the
United States and the threat was totally
empty it's one of those things were
Donald Trump knees done this multiple
times I say I know what's really going
on yeah here or I have this information
that I know that nobody else knows and
I'm gonna tell people at some point uh
he doesn't he's got nothing and I all
ready to hear what he knows right when
we're gonna finally get the real story
of of Obama's birth certificate which is
a years in the making now and when we
hear details of his economic plan or
Isis plan or trade plan or plan for the
wall I'll ed can't get any worse yeah
yeah this is hardly the moat the most
inflammatory thing Joe and Myka have
said about Donald Trump too well there's
been this sort of often on relationship
between Trump in the morning joe people
because remember when the leaked audio
caught Trump talking with mica and Joe
during a break and it looked like they
were all very buddy-buddy remember this
what do you have after this I make a
speech get her a flame make a speech
look at what the Bloomberg oh well all
the pokes out today of a grayble young
Carolina oh yeah we look good well so so
I'm being hit you know they're spending
75 million dollars a negative ads and me
over the last two weeks right are they
catching on it'll know what do you think
are they catching on now delicious
they're spending a tremendous amount on
negative ads on me no you know what i
thought was the kind of wow moment was
the guy you brought up on stage waited
several times it's more they played it
up against obama both guys the both
outside oh yes we played Obama first the
young guy that was hand the guys
actually know what you showed this me
boom you have me almost as a legendary
figure I like no idea this morning when
we basically said today was we were
completely wrong about totally yeah i
thought it i thought i did really well
in the debates today I didn't yes I
ready viewer question you did not right
oh my god but then after being very
buddy buddy Joe Scarborough just a
couple of weeks ago actually said that
Trump didn't seem to understand why he
couldn't just nuke countries so things
going in a different direction with
their relationship take a look several
months ago a foreign policy expert on
international level went to advise
Donald Trump and three times he asked
about the use of nuclear weapons three
times he asked at one point if we have
them why can't we use them that's one of
the reasons why he has he just doesn't
have foreign policy experts around Trump
s 3 times 3 times in an hour briefing
why can't we use nuclear weapons
with that be careful America and be
careful Republican leaders so general
Hayden the problem is blowing up I want
to ask uh so I get that there's some
tension here but I go back to the main
question if a presidential candidate is
threatening media people on social media
that is not someone that should be
President of the United States period no
further discussion is required if I'm
wrong let me know on Twitter at d Pakman
last week we did a story about the
clearly bogus Donald Trump medical
letter talking about how he had done
astonishingly well on every test that
was done back in December we did a
detailed report on it the story did well
we estimate a total viewership of about
350,000 views across all platforms for
that story a ton of emails came in about
it and all of a sudden corporate media
is getting interested in the story Lois
I turn on CNN last night and there's a
panel discussion on Don Lemon show about
the the trustworthiness of Donald
Trump's medical letter looking at
reporting of it today countless websites
talking about it and now that I've had a
little more time to look into this
medical letter about how fantastic and
tremendous Donald Trump's medical state
is and how he's winning again and again
with his with his status of Health it's
even sketchier than we reported last
week so let me get you up to speed let's
first put up the original letter and
I'll just quickly remind you of all the
issues for it number one that the letter
starts with a typo to whom my concern
which is just weird for such a short
letter the letter has a nonworking web
address where when you go to that
website there's just no website
therefore the doctor who supposedly did
this examination uh the doctor number
one included an email address which is
weird because you don't want to get
emails about something like a letter
like this because HIPAA laws would
prevent you from saying anything more
but it's also weird that the email
address listed is a personal gmail
address imagine uh you know hi I'm the
CEO of ford motor company I'd like to do
business with you
please email me at markfield 0236 @
hotmail.com no it doesn't make any sense
so come on uh and then in addition to
that Lenox Hill Hospital has a division
of gastroenterology but for some reason
the signature of trumps letter refers to
the gastroenterology section which dr.
Harold bornstein is not even a part of
at Lenox Hill Hospital and uh lastly the
entire language of the letter where
tests are described as only positive
when in medical language positive means
a test has confirmed a diagnosis or
condition and of course lastly referring
to trump is potentially the healthiest
president ever when there is no way that
Harold bornstein md examined all other
presidents and would have any way of
comparing Trump's health to those other
presidents so every news site has
basically been pointing out how
ridiculous this entire stink thing is
those were the problems we already
reported to you last week we now have
even more insanity to report to you a
number of sites have gone back to look
at Donald Trump's social media posts
when this letter came out you might
remember I told you last week that Jacob
bornstein had actually been deceased for
years at the time of the publication of
this letter and the letter was signed by
at least in this version Harold
bornstein it turns out that Donald Trump
posted to both Facebook and Twitter that
this was a letter signing off on his
tremendously positive health and results
signed by Jacob bornstein a doctor who
had been dead for years at the time this
was released now these posts have been
deleted from the internet but thanks to
something called print screen there are
still records of these and here's the
the Facebook post that Donald Trump put
out back in December saying I am proud
to share this report written by the
highly respected dr. Jacob bornstein of
Lenox Hill Hospital stating that i am in
excellent health unfortunately dr. Jake
bornstein had been dead for years at the
time that Donald Trump publish to
facebook the assertion that this dead
dr. Louis had signed off on how great
Trump's health is this is completely
bogus and we actually need to see
Trump's medical records all the debunk
conspiracies about Hillary Clinton's
health we have no idea what Trump's
medical records actually say and we have
no idea what Trump's tax returns
actually say we have nothing about
Donald Trump that letter at this point
can we say it is absolutely bogus and
fake uh I'm comfortable saying that yes
and I'm far more interested though in
the tax returns than I am Donald Trump's
medical records I I agree uh because I I
don't have any conspiracy theories about
Donald Trump's health but if he has to
fake a letter it's odd yeah why do you
have to fake the letter doesn't really
make any sense so yet this story
completely blowing up we need to demand
not only the tax returns but because
Trump himself has put out what seems to
be a clearly fraudulent letter we also
need to figure out what the hell is
going on as Donald Trump would say with
that medical and health situation the
Fox News sexual harassment scandal has
escalated even more and it now has
pulled in Bill O'Reilly as well as
former host andrea tantaros I'll give
you the background it started with a
lawsuit from former host gretchen
carlson who alleged she was sexually
harassed and asked to do all sorts of
things by roger ailes in order to
continue her position on the network she
says that it was basically a boys club
misogynist sexual harassment totally
normalized sexual harassment situation
twenty other women then came out of the
woodwork megan kelly jumped into the
fray saying yeah this actually does
happen and it led to fox news chief
roger ailes resigning in shame but with
a very very nice reportedly 40 million
dollar golden parachute the latest is
that former for a fox news host andrea
tantaros a right winger a conservative
talker not someone we can write off as
some kind of safe space gloria allred
third wave feminists right we're talking
louis here
out a right-winger she is now filed a
major lawsuit where she claims that
Roger Ailes sexually harassed her that
other high-ranking executives created a
culture of persistently abusive behavior
and and this is where it starts to get
even more interesting it mentions Bill
O'Reilly asserting that Bill O'Reilly
once asked tantaros to stay with him at
a quote very private place in Long
Island and expressed the desire to see
her as a wild girl the lawsuit also
mentions former Massachusetts Republican
Senator Scott Brown who tenth eros
alleges made sexually inappropriate
comments about her including once
grabbing her around the waist when she
was buying lunch Scott Brown responded
to this where else but Twitter saying as
a survivor of sexual abuse i would never
perpetuate language or actions as
described in the Fox complaint the
actions referenced are fabricated listen
if sexual harassment and misogyny at fox
news surprise you you're probably
uninformed enough to be a regular fox
news viewer that there's nothing at all
surprising about this louis or your work
for fox news but uh but the people who
work for fox news uh are some of the
ones making the complaints here and
these are people who have been with the
company for a long time uh what's what's
the goal here they're well paid right i
mean well although there are some Fox
News staffers according to CNN's brian
Stelter who claims to have spoken to
some Fox new staffers on the condition
of anonymity they feel that the the
allegations made by tantaros a sort of
exaggerated they're they're not totally
buying it not really proof of anything
we have it we have allegations we have a
resignation we have 22 women at this
point who have similar stories now if
you're surprised or shocked that bill
o'reilly is mentioned recall that he has
had sexual harassment problems of his
own settling a very high-profile sexual
harassment lawsuit leveled in 2004 by a
producer named andrea macris for
reportedly more than two million dollars
in order to avoid having to admit any
wrongdoing he was charged with talking
to his producer about his personal
sexual fantasies his masturbation her
masturbation vibrators
sometimes reportedly appearing to be
pleasuring himself during the
conversations with Angie Andrea makris
this is all so confusing to me Louis
since Fox News is the only news network
that's really advocating Christian
morality in Christian principles it's
shocking to me that they would have
these issues uh Dave are you being
sarcastic yes you might you might be
being a little sarcastic so to summarize
the full list of andrea tantaros is
claims i'll put this list up for you to
take a look at uh she says that Roger
Ailes allegedly would refer to fox news
host as gay so fat and a Porto Rican
[ __ ] in one case as I mentioned
suggests that bill o'reilly allegedly
suggested a private meeting is his home
to see it to see his uh to see her wild
side she made the Scott Brown
allegations that he made sexually
suggestive remarks on set and also
touched her in a way she didn't like uh
also claiming that Fox News ran their PR
machine with an aggressive campaign to
smear her once she started complaining
and Fox executive bill shine allegedly
advised andrea tantaros to just let the
allegations go we will see where this
leads this does not seem to be going
away Louis we thought well maybe with
the ales resignation it'll go away but
we've actually seen it become an even
bigger story since then and I can't
imagine there are many more people
waiting in in the board work to to come
out and you think the 22 might be the
full lot of them it could be yeah but
that's substantial ultimately is this
going to to hurt fox news and and lower
viewership no I had other viewers will
chalk it up to a liberal media
conspiracy or something yeah yeah or
just uh some type of misogynistic excuse
oh yeah Yello that they've actually
already it's funny I've noticed other
corporate media outlets they do mention
this story sometimes but they're pretty
light about it almost like they say
we're gonna play kinda nice with the
other networks and it's actually making
it even harder to make the case that
this is all a so-called liberal media
smear because actually corporate media
has been sort of light handed on this
yeah well if I had to guess I'd say that
this is happening in in far more places
than just
fox news studio yeah well that would be
another reason why other media outlets
may want not want to be too harsh
because they may not want the
investigations turned on to them after
the break we will speak to the great
Chris Martenson it's been a couple years
since he's been on and I really look
forward to speaking with him let's talk
about Bill Nye the Science Guy CNN
brought on Bill Nye the Science Guy
yesterday to talk about the horrific
flooding that we've been seeing in
Louisiana even in more inland areas of
Louisiana as i told you that don't
typically flood that don't require home
insurance if you own a home in those
areas at least 13 people have died a
sixty thousand or more homes have been
damaged and we've been making this a
story about climate change because
that's really what we're talking about
and it's important to distinguish
between individual weather events and
broader climate change but as I've said
it before I probably fleet feel like a
broken record at this point when we see
climate change we are going to see more
erratic weather events the weather
events themselves are not the climate
change but it will be a sort of symptom
and consequence of climate change bill
nye you could tell during this
five-minute interview there was
something he wanted to say he was sort
of holding back and then at the end
during this interview with chris cuomo
he drops it and it's accusing CNN of
having a climate denying meteorologist
on the air let's take a look at the
video breaking you would not need to
have a military on the other side of the
world protecting oil fields people would
not be as motivated to set oilfield fire
if we had renewable electricity here a
big issue that we see world or the wet
see hanging it over lots of part parts
of life let's art parts of life let's
see what happens in coming out you know
here at CNN you have a essentially a
climate change denier meteorologist and
knock yourselves out but this is a big
problem and it's not going to away a
bigger conversation for another day bill
night preciate ya not something we're
gonna talk about today so bill nye
didn't mention any names but it's pretty
clear he's referring to CNN
meteorologist chad myers who does have a
track record of making comments about
climate change he once said that there's
it's just very arrogant to think that
humans could actually do anything on the
planet to impact the climate etcetera
etcetera whenever I hear that uh the the
whoa that's a different conversation for
a different day I always think that
those will be the that that will be the
death knell of the human race hey you
know what that conversation that's a
conversation for a different day like
those facts in those figures and
although that reality of everyday yet
that's other cars conversation other day
now in in Chad Myers is defense he went
on Twitter and he actually made two
tweets about this the first one which I
will put up for you here Chad Myers said
not me moved to climate change in 2009
and then actually following that up
again with another tweet where he said
uh what did he say this one is not it
but anyway he added a scientist can be
swayed by data and I was so I have sort
of mixed feelings about this Rachel on
the one hand some people are saying bill
nye is hugely courageous he went on CNN
and he said to them you were part of the
problem you have this climate change
denier on the air at the same time you
could make the argument that Bill Nye
showed up uninformed not realizing that
Chad Myers no longer supported those
climate change denial ideas of 2009 or
2010 hero courageous uh ignorant
uninformed I don't know well it's
interesting because there was an
interview so he was he was prompted in
this interview but he did say that he
wished that climate deniers there would
be a lot to punish them oh yeah yeah in
another interview exactly in another
interview so would that be a violation a
free speech then yes some people are
writing to me and they're like you know
the optics are that Bill Nye showed up
and he did a really great thing but if
you actually consider that Chad Myers
has changed his his view on this and
number two that once Bill Nye called for
punishment for climate deniers and what
is that I mean that when we talk about
violations of free speech and and sort
of thought police when I hear a
punishment for climate deniers I
understand punishment or taxation for
companies that are producing emitting
carbon into the atmosphere sort of get
that legislatively I never got
clarification on what Bill Nye meant
Louis about upon
ishment for climate deniers yeah legal
punishment perhaps not should we should
we persecute them absolutely and while
he may have gone a little overboard here
been a bit misinformed uh it's he's
using his celebrity and his influence to
uh to help fight this this false
equivalency issue that the corporate
media has when it comes to climate
change and that's massively important if
nothing else Jason can we praise Bill
Nye because by doing this he was at
least taking a risk that CNN would
blacklist him and that he wouldn't be
allowed back on and to a certain degree
is there some courage in that I say
certainly I mean to actually stand up
for the truth and you know so easy just
to go with the big dollar money you know
propaganda that's out there and ride
that wave but back to the point I mean I
think what he's looking for is like a
game of thrones asked shaming really
everyone has we walk down the streets
everyone yells shame at them maybe maybe
that will get them to actually realize
that you know this actually is reality I
don't know not a fine for what you say
but publicly ostracizing people I'm so
sick of this that's a different
conversation thing that we sometimes
hear on corporate media because the
conversation basically was hey what's
happening with these storms and floods
will there be more what can we do and
then the expert says well what we need
to look at his global climate change and
and CNN is arguably part of that problem
with this meteorologist oh that's a
bigger issue for another day now it's
kind of actually the issue we're talking
about today isn't it right i kind of
just feel like that's a cop-out to not
have to address a larger narrative
that's going on